-Congress has been rocked
by its own sexual
misconduct allegations this week
with Senator Al Franken
being accused
of sexual harassment.
Yet more women coming forward to
accuse Alabama Senate candidate
Roy Moore of sexually assaulting
them as teenagers.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The avalanche
of sexual harassment allegations
in the last few weeks has shown
us that predatory behavior
is everywhere in virtually
every aspect of society --
in the news business,
in entertainment,
and in politics.
Every day,
there are more revelations,
and this week,
we started to get a sense
of just how pervasive sexual
harassment is in Congress, too.
-There are two members
of Congress,
Republican and Democrat,
right now, who serve,
who have been subject to review,
or not have been
subject to review,
but have engaged
in sexual harassment.
These harasser propositions,
such as,
"Are you going
to be a good girl?"
to perpetrators
exposing their genitals,
to victims having
their private parts
grabbed on the House floor.
-That is awful.
I'd say Congress
is full of dicks,
but most of them
look more like ball sacks.
[ Laughter ]
And today, we also learned,
yet again,
as if more evidence was needed,
that this is not
a partisan problem.
There are sexual harassers
of all political persuasions
in both parties.
Take Minnesota Senator
Al Franken.
Today, an anchor for KABC
in Los Angeles
said, "Senator Al Franken
kissed and groped me
without my consent
during a USO tour in 2006,"
and shared this photo
of Franken groping her
while she was asleep.
That is horrifying.
And she's wearing Army gear
because it's a USO tour,
but, honestly,
who could blame women
if they started
wearing military gear
whenever they're around men?
"Where are you going
in a helmet and a flak jacket?"
"The subway."
[ Laughter ]
This is a pervasive problem that
affects every aspect of society
and every political party,
and everyone
should be held accountable,
from Al Franken to Roy Moore
to Bill Clinton
to the current President
of the United States.
And yet amid all of this,
there are still Republicans
defending Moore, their nominee
for Senate in Alabama,
who, of course, has been accused
of sexually assaulting
underage girls.
Take, for example,
Alabama Congressman, Mo Brooks,
who said he still plans
to support Moore
because the conservative agenda
is vastly more important
than contested
sexual allegations
from four decades ago.
An ABC reporter
tried to ask Brooks
if he believes
the very credible accounts
of the women who accused Moore
of sexual assault,
and Brooks literally ran away
from him during the interview.
[ Shoes tapping ]
"Bad day to wear my tap shoes."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I'd tell Mo Brooks
to go to hell,
but it looks like
that's where he's trying to get.
[ Laughter ]
That whole scene reminds me
of the M.C. Escher drawing
titled "The Chicken [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
Of course, part of the reason
Republicans are so desperate
to ignore questions about Moore
is that even the ones who say
they believe his accusers
can't explain why they don't
also believe the women
who have accused President Trump
of sexual assault.
A reporter for
The Huffington Post
valiantly tried to get
Wyoming Senator Mike Enzi
to answer that question,
but Enzi wouldn't budge.
[ Laughter ]
You've got to admire --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've got to admire
The Huffington Post's effort.
Reporters should just
keep doing that
until Republicans
answer the questions.
"Look, I just want to talk
about building a wall."
"Okay. should we build a wall
between teenagers
and Roy Moore?"
[ Laughter ]
A reporter for NBC News
similarly tried
to get an answer about Moore
from Arkansas Republican Senator
Tom Cotton with no luck.
Here's that transcript.
So, technically,
the elevators had more to say
in that transcript
than Tom Cotton.
So, hey, elevator, do you think
Roy Moore should drop out?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The refusal by many Republicans,
including the President,
to discuss Moore's situation
comes as we keep
getting information
about how creepy
his behavior was.
Earlier this week,
it was reported that Moore
was actually banned from
the Gadsden Mall and the YMCA.
He got banned from the YMCA
despite dressing exactly
like one of The Village People.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, yesterday, on MSNBC,
Moore's lawyer, Trenton Garmon,
tried to dispute the claim that
Moore was banned from the mall,
but in the process,
he seemed to confirm
that there were, indeed,
complaints about his behavior.
-I was engaged in litigation
with the Gadsden Mall.
It had a settlement
that was confidential.
I'm intimately familiar
with the procedures
inside of the Gadsden Mall,
and from what I have been told,
has never been a list
with Roy Moore
banned from being at the mall.
So they processed that out,
and they determined,
"No, whatever it is
that someone has said
has made them uncomfortable,
we don't find it to be worthy
to put them on a list.
-Is it not cause for concern
that there would even be
any sort of settlement
with the Gadsden Mall?
Roy Moore was in his 30s.
What type of settlement
would there be?
-[ Clears throat ]
No, there was not
a settlement with Roy Moore,
had nothing to do --
Roy Moore has never had
a settlement
with the Gadsden Mall.
I'm talking about my personal
experience as a litigator.
I have represented people
against the Gadsden Mall.
-Wait. You've been a lawyer in
other cases of People v. Mall?
[ Laughter ]
So I guess that
you've been banned from the mall
and need a lawyer,
Trenton Garmon is your man.
[ Laughter ]
But the weirdest
part of the interview
that Moore's lawyer
gave to MSNBC
came when he tried to defend
Moore's claim
that he always
asked for permission
from a girl's mother
before dating her.
Garmon tried to argue that
that kind of behavior
was common in other cultures,
and threw in some gross racism
when he tried to cite
MSNBC anchor Ali Velshi's
background to bolster his case.
-Why would he need permission
from any of these girls' mothers
if they weren't underage?
-Not underage.
-Sure, that's a good question.
Culturally speaking,
I would say there's differences.
I looked up
Ali's background there.
And, wow, that's awesome
that you have got
such a diverse background.
It's really cool
to read through that.
But point is this --
-What does Ali's background have
to do with dating a 14-year-old?
-I'm not finished
with the context of it.
-Well, please answer.
What does Ali Velshi's
background have to do
with dating under-- children,
14-year-old girls?
-Sure.
In other countries,
there's arrangement
through parents
for what we would refer to...
-Ali's from Canada.
-as consensual marriage.
[ Laughter ]
-So, either Trenton Garmon
is a racist,
or he thinks Canada
has arranged marriages.
And yet in spite
of all this damning evidence
about Moore's predatory
and grotesque behavior,
Trump still has said nothing
about what Moore should do.
In fact, yesterday,
he spoke at the White House
about his trip to Asia,
and completely ignored questions
about Moore from reporters.
-America is back.
And the future
has never looked brighter.
Thank you, God bless you,
and God bless
the United States of America.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you all.
-Should Roy Moore resign,
Mr. President?
Do you believe his accusers?
Do you believe his accusers of
Roy Moore, Mr. President?
Should he resign?
-If the future is so bright,
why do you look so bummed out
walking away?
"Everything is great,
and there's nothing
to be upset about."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And while some Republicans
are desperate
to ignore the questions,
others are urging Trump
to take a stand,
like South Carolina Senator,
Lindsey Graham,
who had this to say about Moore.
-I met a lot of people
in the mall,
and if you get kicked out
of the mall,
that's a pretty bad situation
to find yourself in.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I agree,
but why have you met
a lot of people in the mall?
"I got a booth.
It's called Lindsey's Nut Hut.
It's mostly pecans.
Those pecans
are as sweets as old Lindsey."
[ Laughter ]
This is a society-wide problem
borne out of systemic misogyny
and abuse of power,
and both parties
need to take it seriously,
no matter who's accused.
Don't you agree,
Congressman Mo Brooks?
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]